In the meme app,
we need to show the Activity view in
order to enable users to share memes.
Let's go back into our
experiment app and
see about presenting
the ActivityViewController.
We'll start out with just
an empty image object,
we can then use that image to
instantiate a UI ActivityViewController.
And then we just present it.
Let's see how that worked.
And there's our Activity View.
One can make an alert
view in a similar way.
Here we're just constructing
our AlertViewController and
presenting it and
then we'll try and run it, and
then we'll try and
present our AlertViewController.
Oh, uh-oh, okay.
So let's scroll up to the top of
the console to see what's going on.
URL alert controller must have a title,
a message, or an action to display.
Okay, so if we add one of those,
this should fix the error.
So we'll try that.
Let's close the console up.
And then we'll return to our
ViewController and close that too.
So here we're adding a title and
a message to our AlertViewController, so
let's see if that fixes the problem.
All right,
show me an Alert View hey, sweet.
Okay, now we're successfully
presenting our AlertViewController, but
right now there's no
way to make it go away.
Remember that any time
you present a view,
you also need to provide the user
with a way to dismiss it.
The first two view controllers
we presented had their
own Cancel buttons built in,
but Alert View doesn't have that, so
we have to solve the problem ourselves.
We could just try adding this
dismissViewController method right after
presentViewController.
Let's see what that does.
Okay, show me an alert view oh,
well it showed me an alert view but
then the alert view immediately left.
Which is not that surprising since we
called dismissViewController immediately
after we called presentViewController.
What we really want is for the AlertView
to be dismissed after the user has taken
some action like clicking an OK button.
AlertView has an interesting
way to do this with closures.
As you know, closures like this one,
enable us to pass methods
around as arguments.
So let's see how that looks.
Okay, our AlertView appears,
I click OK, and it goes away.
Perfect.